willkommen meine Damen und Herren zu
Phönix Vorort 14 Oktober 2023 hinter mir
Livebilder über dem Luftraum aus Gaza
geschossen das ist unser Update zur Lage
im Nahen Osten für Sie genau vor einer
Woche begannen die Terrorangriffe der
Hamas auf Israel international gilt das
bereits als der 911 Moment für Israel
das israelische Militär hat die Frist
für die evak ung jetzt noch einmal
verlängert bis zum Nachmittag aber ob
die Zahl die Zeit ausreicht für 1,1
Millionen Menschen den Norden des
Gazastreifens zu verlassen ist völlig
offen die israelische Luftwaffe flog
auch in der Nacht Angriffe auf den
Gazastreifen im Hintergrund laufen
weiter die Vorbereitungen für die
Bodenoffensive Notizen aus Israel und
dem
Gazastreifen das israelische Militär hat
bei den Luftangriffen nach e Angaben
einen hochrangigen hamaskmandeur getötet
er sei maßgeblich für die Steuerung der
Terroristen während der Angriffe auf
israelische Zivilisten vergangenes
Wochenende verantwortlich gewesen so die
Armee Premierminister Netanyahu stimmte
die israelische Bevölkerung auf einen
langen Kampf gegen die Hamas
ein das ist erst der Anfang unsere
Feinde haben gerade erst begonnen den
Preis zu bezahlen ich kann nicht
enthüllen was passieren wird aber ich
kann sagen dass das jetzt erst der
Anfang
ist der Beginn der Bodenoffensive rückt
offenbar immer näher in Gaza sind
100.000 Menschen weiter auf der Flucht
in Richtung Süden die israelische Armee
kündigte an bis zum späten Nachmittag
hinein eine sichere Passage auf zwei
Straßen zu
gewährleisten die Zivilisten sind nicht
unsere Feinde wir versuchen Sie nicht zu
töten oder zu verletzen wir kämpfen
gegen die Hamas das muss ein für alle
Mal klar sein unser Ziel ist die Hamas
und ih militärische
Infrastruktur aber auch die zivile
Infrastruktur ist betroffen den Menschen
fehlt es am nötigsten Wasservorräte
werden knapp wir haben kaum noch Wasser
nur eine Firma versorgt uns derzeit noch
damit Gott weiß was in zwei D Tagen
passiert unter den momentanen Umständen
unterdessen hat die chamas nach eigenen
Angaben allein gestern erneut mehr als
150 Raketen in Richtung der Stadt
Aschkelon in der Nähe des Gazastreifens
abgefeuert die Hamas veröffentlicht
heute Aufnahmen von mit Sprengstoff
beladenen Drohnen die gezielt gegen
israelische Ziele gelenkt werden an der
Grenze zum Gazastreifen herrscht immer
wieder raketenalarm Soldaten suchen
Schutz hinter Panzern wir wollen diese
Information noch etwas hinterfragen und
freuen uns dass wir in Tel Aviv
verbunden sind mit ZF Korrespondent l
walport Herr walport wenn wir erstmal
auf diese aktuelle Lage schauen was
haben die letzten Stunden gebracht an
Entwicklungen ja wir haben es im Beitrag
ja gesehen es gibt weiter
Raketenbeschuss sowohl aus Gaza heraus
also Hamas Raketen in Richtung Israel es
gab auch hier in Tel Aviv wieder vor
zwei Stunden Alarmsirenen
diese Geschosse wurden of mal in der
Luft abgefangen es gab keine Schäden am
Boden
und dann gab es eben auch heute früh
wieder Beschuss von hamasstellungen
im Gazastreifen im nördlichen
Gazastreifen von den israelischen
Streitkräften ansonsten ist es sehr
ruhig hier heute in der Stadt Tel Aviv
aber das hat auch mit dem mit der
Tatsache zu tun dass wir heute Schabbat
also am Samstag dem jüdischen Feiertag
sind und deswegen das Leben ohne hin
eher ruhig ist und alle bereiten sich
eben bange vor auf die Frage wann geht
es los wann werden israelische Truppen
über den grenzzun in Gaza nach Gaza
vordringen und hinter den Kulissen gibt
es eben auch hektische Diplomatie rund
um Israel herum in den arabischen
Ländern wo viele Vermittler versuchen
das schwerelos der Zivilbevölkerung Gaza
durch Kompromisse etwas
aufzubessern lassen Sie uns das
nacheinander noch ein bisschen
durchgehen sie haben das angesprochen es
gibt extern die mahnenden Stimmen die
auch noch mal auf die Regeln des Krieges
durchaus hinweisen die kommen z.B von
den Vereinten Nationen noch mal
formuliert gestern Abend in New York wie
wird das aufgenommen
Israel gemischt es gibt natürlich eine
Menge Menschen denen klar ist was das
für die Zivilbevölkerung heißt im Moment
im Gaza diese komplette Abriegelung des
Gazastreifens und die Aufforderung der
israelischen Streitkräfte den Norden
dieses Gebietes also fast mehr als eine
Million Zivilisten zu räumen zu
evakuieren sich in den Süden zu begeben
wo gar keine Aufnahmekapazitäten dafür
da sind wen weder Wohnungen noch
Nahrungsmittel noch Wasser noch Strom
also das ist vielen Israelis hier auch
klar aber das muss man ganz klar sagen
ein großes aber
die Bevölkerung steht immer noch unter
Schock nach diesen unglaublichen
Massakern der Hamas vom letzten
Wochenende und das wird jetzt hier nicht
tiefergehend diskutiert was
die israelischen Streitkräfte da jetzt
vorbereiten in Gaza man vertraut darauf
dass die israelische Armee sich an das
Kriegsvölkerrecht hält ein Sprecher der
israelischen Armee hat vor ein am Morgen
in einem Briefing noch einmal eindeutig
gesagt die Gegner der Armee sind die
Hamas wir zielen nicht auf die
Zivilbevölkerung aber jeder weiß dass es
äh enorme Kollateralschäden gibt dass
die Zivilbevölkerung natürlich in
Mitleidenschaft gezogen wird wenn die
Panzer und Truppen erst einmal
vordringen sollten nach Gaza und auch
die Differenzierung dürfte dann schwer
werden zwischen Zivilisten und Kämpfern
tatsächlich zu unterscheiden wenn diese
Bodenoffensive beginnt kann man sonst
noch aus der Erfahrung im Nahen Osten
sagen was es für Anzeichen geben würde
sie haben gesagt es läuft im Hintergrund
alles weiter die Vorbereitung äh wann es
losgeht also nicht an diesem Feiertag
aber möglicherweise in den folgenden
Stunden das ist schwer zu sagen es wird
sicher nicht mehr Wochen dauern denn der
Aufmarsch das muss man auch sehen hat
auch wirtschaftliche Konsequenzen für
Israel es sind mehr als 300 000
Reservisten zu den Waffen gerufen worden
das hat enorme Auswirkung auf das
Wirtschaftsleben hier in Israel es ist
jetzt nicht so dass die Armee dort Tage
oder Wochen lang am Gazastreifen
ausharen kann und
warten kann bis die Gelegenheit günstig
ist also wir reden hier von Stunden oder
Tagen maximal im Hintergrund wie ich
sagte gibt es aber eine mächtige
diplomatische Initiative unter anderem
der Amerikaner aber auch europäische
Verhandlungspartner
die deutsche Außenministerin Annalena
berburg ist heute in Ciro
der US-Außenminister war gestern in
Qatar und hat versucht auch Ägypten
davon zu überzeugen den einzigen
Grenzübergang der von Gaza nicht auf
israelisches Gebiet führt nämlich Rafa
an der Grenze zum Sinai den zu öffnen
zumindest für humanitäre
Hilfslieferungen es ist bereits ein
erstes Flugzeug mit medizinischen
Hilfsgütern von der
Weltgesundheitsorganisation nah bei
diesem Grenzübergang gelandet in der
nordostägyptischen Stadt alaris auf dem
Sinai also man hofft dass man Ägypten
dazu bringen kann einen humanitären
Korridor zu öffnen aber das ist noch
nicht geschehen das wäre das was man
unter Substanz der politischen Besuche
in der Region zusammenfassen kann ein
allerletzter Punkt Herr wahlport
viele fragen sich nach wie vor nach dem
Zustand und dem aufentaltsort der
Geiseln gibt es da jetzt neue
Erkenntnisse wenn es die gibt wenn die
israelischen sicherheitsbhörden die
haben teilen Sie sie nicht mit und das
ist offengestanden natürlich kein gutes
Zeichen ähm es gibt sehr wenige
Informationen im Prinzip nur das was
seit letztem Wochenende bekannt ist
nicht einmal die präzise Zahl der
israelischen und ausländischen Geiseln
in der Hand der Hamas haben wir aber es
steht außer Frage Hamas hat ja in einer
mit einem enormen Zynismus klar gemacht
dass sie diese Menschen
selbstverständlich als menschliche
Schutzschilde einetzen werden und dass
sie auch Geiseln das haben sie
jedenfalls gedroht mit zu töten wenn der
Angriff losgehen sollte also muss man
sich um das Schicksal dieser Menschen
erhebliche Sorgen machen zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt aber Informationen von
israelischer Seite gibt es da nicht
herzlichen Dank lü wahport CDF
Korrespondentin Tel Aviv für ihre
Einschätzung Information heute hier bei
phöniix
merci meine Damen und Herren die
humanitäre Lage in Gaza wir haben sie
bereits angesprochen ist extrem
angespannt und sie scheint im Moment
aussichtslos Leute verlassen ihre Häuser
sind auf der Flucht aber auch die
Krankenhäuser sind am Anschlag und sind
zum Teil schon überfüllt die Notizen des
gestrigen Tages dazu hat Philip
kunschner im folgenden Beitrag
gesammelt im Morgengrauen ist Gaza noch
immer das Ziel von Raketen oben die
Einschläge unten in Kellern suchen
Menschen nach etwas Schutz wir sind von
der Außenwelt abgeschnitten wir wissen
nicht was da oben gerade passiert wir
wissen nicht was mit uns passieren wird
wie unser Schicksal aussieht wir wissen
noch nicht einmal wohin wenn wir hier
rauskommen Stunden später dann fallen
Flugblätter vom Himmel abgeworfen von
drohen die israelische Armee ruft die
palästin Zivilbevölkerung auf den Norden
des gaserstreifens zu verlassen mehr als
eine Million Menschen sollen sich auf
die Flucht begeben in Richtung Süden weg
von Gaza
Stadt jemand muss uns retten wir begeben
uns auf einen kollektiven Selbstmord was
hier passiert ist nicht zu akzeptieren
was haben wir denn getan dass wir jetzt
obdachlos
werden sie haben Zettel abgeworfen sie
wollen dass wir gehen warum wegen all
der Dinge die hier passieren
werden
der Aufruf den dicht besiedelten Norden
des gaserstreifens zu verlassen der
bislang deutlichste Hinweis auf eine
bevorstehende bodeninvasion der
israelischen Armee seit dem Überfall der
Hamas feuert Israel immer wieder auf
Ziele im Gazastreifen seit Samstag die
Angriffe sollen sich gegen die
Infrastruktur der Hamas richten die sich
oft in mitten von Wohngebieten befindet
das Bild auf den Straßen schon jetzt
eine Trümmerlandschaft von zerstörten
Wohnungen und Häusern mehr als 1 und 800
Menschen sind nach palästinensischen
Angaben bisher gestorben Überlebenden
bleibt oft nicht mehr als das was sie
tragen können ztausende haben sich auf
die Flucht begeben auf den Straßen Chaos
und lange Staus sie versuchen
rechtzeitig in den Süden des
gaserstreifens zu gelangen all diese
Bilder die wir ihn jetzt gezeigt haben
die hat man auch gesehen in New York bei
den Vereinten Nationen am hudsen River
wo man gut und sicher sitzt aber
trotzdem sehr besorgt ist über diese
Lage wo man gestern Abend noch einmal in
einer geschlossenen Sitzung getagt hat
weil ja die Sitzung am Montag
tatsächlich ergebnislos auch geblieben
ist wegen der Vetorechte die im
Sicherheitsrat bestehen aber trotzdem
gibt es den UNO Generalsekretär gibt es
Antonio guteres der noch mal darauf
hinweist dass man von allen Seiten die
Regeln des Krieges beachten sollte das
hat er noch mal in einem Statement
getan ich möchte hier ganz kurz auf die
wichtigsten Botschaften eingehen die ich
dann dem Sicherheitsrat vorlegen werde
die Lage in Gaza hat ein gefährliches
neues Tief erreicht die abscheulichen
Terroranschläge von Hamas auf Israel
haben mehr als 12 Menschen getötet und
tausende verletzte am letzten Samstag
darauf folgte eine intensive
Bombardierung von Gaza dami sind schon
1800 Menschen ums Leben gekommen und
tausende weitere verletzt nach
verschiedenen Luftschlägen hatte Israel
die Palästinenser in Gaza stad und der
Umgebung aufgefordert in den Süden des
Gazastreifen sich zu begeben aber mehr
als eine Million Menschen durch eine
dicht besiedelte Kriegszone an einen Ort
zu bringen wo es keine Nahrungsmittel
gibt kein Wasser keine Unterkünft wenn
das gesamte Gebiet belagert ist ist
äußerst gefährlich in einigen Fällen
nicht möglich die krankenhäus im Süden
des
gasstreifens operieren schon am Rande
ihrer Kapazitäten und sind nicht in der
Lage Taus neue
das Gesundheitssystem steht vor dem
Zusammenbruch die Stationen sind
übervoll mehr als 11 Anger des
medizinischen Personals wurden in
Ausübung ihrer Tätigkeit getöt und es
gab 34 Angriffe auf
gesundheitsinrichtung im ganzen Gebiet
herrscht eine Wasserkrise die
Infrastruktur ist zerstörtt kein Strom
für Pumpen und
ungsanlagen
die ariter
der UNO und unsere Partner arbeiten rund
um die Uhr um die Menschen im gazen zu
unterstützen wir betrauern den Tod einer
Reihen von Kollegen und wahrscheinlich
werden noch mehr ihr Leben riskieren ich
stehe in Kontakt mit politischen Führern
weltweit und in der Region um eine
weitere
Eskalation im westlderland und auch im
Südlibanon zu verhindern der
feuerwechsel über die blaue Linie hinweg
ist äerst unruhigen das muss aufhören
wir brauchen sofortigen humanitären
Zugang zum gazastrafen und den
Bedürftigen Treibstoff Nahrungsmittel
und Wasser zu liefern auch Kriege haben
ihre Regeln das internationale
humanitärrecht und Menschenrecht muss
geachtet werden Zivilisten müssen
geschützt werden und dürfen nie als
Schutzschilde benutzt werden und alle
Geisel in Gaza müssen sofort
freigelassen werden es ist wichtig dass
alle Parteien und diejenigen die
Einfluss a sie haben alles tun um diese
Ziele zu erreich
und zum Schluss möchte ich noch kurz
eingehen auf den Hass der durch diesen
fürchterlichen Konflikt angestachelt
wurde im Nahen Osten und weltweit
entmenschlichende Sprache die zur Gewalt
auffördert kann man nie akzeptieren ich
fordere alle auf vorzugehen gegen
Antisemitismus und antimuslimische
Heuchelei und Hassrede jetzt ist an der
Zeit dass die Gemeinschaft
zusammrit um Zivilisten en und eine
dauerhafte Lösung für diesen nicht
endenden Zyklus von Tod und Zerstörung
zu finden der Generalsekretär der
Vereinten Nationen das war in New York
gestern Abend jetzt sind wir in Tel Aviv
im militärischen Hauptquartier Israels
verbunden mit Arie schalikar Sprecher
der Israel Defense Forces IDF grüße sie
nach Tel Aviv Herr
schalikar Shalom ich grüße sie zurück
reden wir zunächst über den
evakuierungsaufruf der ja ein großes
Echo gefunden hat eine große Resonanz
auch international das waren nicht nur
positive Stimmen welche Resonanz
verzeichnen Sie wie viele haben sich auf
den Weg gemacht es sind ja über eine
Million
Menschen ja also bei uns äh sind nur
nicht finden nicht nur Worte statt
sondern auch Taten und die Taten sind
wie folgt wir haben die Menschen im
gaserstreifen aufgefordert den
nördlichen gaserstreifen undon hier auf
zwei Routen zu verlassen Richtung
südlichen gaserstreifen weil der
nördliche
geiserstreifen ist das Hauptquartier der
Hamas Hamas befindet sich in Gaza City
und das ist in erster Linie den Raum den
wir natürlich in Zukunft angreifen
wollen um die Terroristen zu finden und
den Raum sage ich jetzt mal von Terror
zu befreien ja schalik das war ja ein
relativ enges Zeitfenster was sie
anfangs gesetzt hatten von 24 Stunden
das sind ja auch alte Menschen das sind
klein Familien mit kleinen Kindern das
sind auch Behinderte äh mit dabei und
das ist jetzt nicht so besonders
gutwegiges Gelände äh insofern äh sie
verlängern diesen Zeitraum jetzt
ja also zum einen ä natürlich
liegt uns nicht daran zivile Opfer zu
sehen uns geht's nicht darum Menschen
anzugreifen die nichts äh verbrochen
haben jedoch dürfen wir kein Mittler
zeigen für die Terroristen der Hamas und
des islamischen Jihads die genau vor
einer Woche 1300 Menschen auf
israelischer Seite niedergemetzelt haben
und das mit einem Lachen auf dem Gesicht
und sie dürfen nicht davon kommen diese
1300 Menschen leben nicht mehr sie haben
ihre Familien verlassen auf grausamsten
Wege die Menschen im nördlichen
gaserstreifen können jetzt ihr Leben
noch retten niemand will ihn etwas antun
und deshalb bitte ich auf diesem Wege
noch einmal bitte in den nächsten
Stunden alles packen was man packen kann
und den südlichen gaserastreifen gehen
in diesen nächsten Tag und Wochen Geduld
haben bis es hoffentlich ruhiger wird um
das Leben zu
retten wie lautet die neue Frist gibt es
eine neue
Uhrzeit also heute ist die erste Frist
natürlich wir sagen ja schon seit
gestern die Menschen sollen sich bewegen
aber wir sehen dass die Hamas alles
daran setzt die Menschen davon
abzuhalten ihre Wohnung zu verlassen um
Ihnen als menschliche Schutzschilder zu
dienen und das zeigt wer eigentlich
schuldig ist für jedes zivile Opfer im
gazastreiben das ist nicht Israel das
ist nicht die israelische Armee sondern
das ist die Hamas und die Fakten sind
klar deshalb sollte eigentlich die Hamas
gefragt werden was tut eigentlich die
Hamas in diesen Tagen um ihre
Zivilbevölkerung in Schutz zu nehmen bzw
sie zu evakuieren sie tun gar nichts
dafür nicht nur dass sie nichts tun sie
tun genau das Gegenteil sie wollen sie
genau dort haben wo sie ihre
terrorinfrastruktur haben wo sie Geiseln
hingeschleppt haben und wo sie die
israelische Armee erwarten mhm es ist
natürlich eine hohe Problematik und
vielleicht auch ein Zögern bei der
Bevölkerung denn ähm einer der höchst
besesiedeltsten Gebiete überhaupt auf
der Welt der Gazastreifen und die Frage
ist äh einen Weg ins Nirgendwo wo kommt
man an diese Frage können Sie
wahrscheinlich auch nicht stabil
beantworten nicht
wahr ich kann folgendes beantworten dass
auf israelischer Seite jetzt seit einer
Woche einige Millionen Menschen Israelis
nicht mehr in ihren Wohnungen leben wie
vor einer Woche noch der gesamte Südraum
in Israel ist jetzt schon evakuiert
Menschen leben nicht mehr unter ihren
Liebsten der gesamte Nordraum ist schon
halbleer Menschen sind Richtung Zentrum
gezogen viele Familien sind jetzt schon
im Ausland leben nicht mehr in Israel
warum weil ihen das Leben wichtiger ist
als jetzt Helden zu spielen und genau
dasselbe erwarten wir natürlich auch vom
Gazastreifen und dass die Hamas genau
dasselbe ihren Leuten empfiehlt sie tun
es jedoch nicht weil sie wollen die
Bilder von zivilen Opfern die wir
natürlich nicht wollen schalika Herr net
jao der Ministerpräsident
Premierminister hat gestern abend gesagt
wir werden Hamas eindeutig vernichten
und zwar jeden Mann es gibt Berichte
darüber dass zumindestens eine
maßgebliche Figur einen maßgeblichen
drahzieher der Vorgänge vom letzten
Wochenende in die Hände der israelischen
Armee gefallen ist gestern Abend wo es
leichte Übertritte bereits gegeben hat
die manche schon interpretiert haben als
den Beginn der Bodenoffensive was genau
ist da
passiert na ja also äh in den letzten
Tagen natürlich sind wir am gezielten äh
Angreifen von terrorinfrastruktur die
kritisch ist die man außer Gefecht
setzen muss aber auch von Terroristen
von führenden Terroristen selbst und wir
haben in den letzten Tagen eine ganze
Handvoll Terroristen hochrangige
Terroristen der Hamas und des
islamischen dihad jetzt schon
neutralisiert die sich im Gasastreifen
befunden haben und es werden noch mehr
werden die kein es wird keinen Weg für
sie drum herumgeben wir haben sie alle
im Visier und das ist eines der Ziele
der israelischen Armee die Hamas und den
islamischen dihad komplett zu vernichten
dass sie nie wieder nie wieder imstande
sein werden ein so dermaßig schlimmes
Massaker an Juden und an Israelis wieder
auszurichten zu dieser Stunde auch wenn
das schwierig ist darauf für Sie zu
antworten kann man davon ausgehen dass
die Mehrheit der Geisel noch am Leben
ist ich kann keine auskunftte geben über
die Lage der Geiseln aber ich erwarte
von der Welt insbesondere von den
Vereinten Nationen und natürlich unseren
Freunden in Deutschland dass das ein
Thema ist
die von ganz ganz oben her
besprochen werden sollte und hoffentlich
dass wir die Geiseln mittlerweile 120
mindestens dass wir sie eines Tages
gesund und lebendig wieder in Israel
umarmen dürfen das war noch einmal
Ausdruck der Hoffnung von Aria
charusalikar Sprecher der Israel Defense
Forces danke für diese Information diese
Position heute Mittag hier bei
phöniix
danke meine Damen und Herren natürlich
hat dieses ganze eine völkerrechtliche
Dimension natürlich schauen alle die
sich mit juristischen Fragen
beschäftigen auf diesen Punkt die Frage
der Unterscheidung zwischen zivilen und
militärischen Zielen Einschätzungen dazu
jetzt aus Karlsruhe vom
rechtspolitischen Korrespondenten der
ARD von Kolja
schwarz die meisten völkerrechtlich
Rechtler sind sich einig dass Israel ein
Selbstverteidigungsrecht zusteht auch
wenn das Land nicht von einem anderen
Staat sondern hier von einer
Terrororganisation der Hamas angegriffen
worden ist und dieses
Selbstverteidigungsrecht würde dann
bedeuten dass Israel tatsächlich alles
tun darf um diesen Angriff abzuwehren
dazu dürfte wohl auch die Bodenoffensive
gehören zumindest wenn man begründen
kann dass das aus der Luft nicht möglich
ist diesen Angriff so effektiv
abzuwehren aber alles was ist Israel tut
muss natürlich nach den Regeln und in
den Grenzen des humanitären Völkerrechts
Ablaufen der wichtigste Grundsatz ist
die
größtmögliche Schonung der
Zivilbevölkerung das heißt Israel darf
nur Kämpfer der Hammers angreifen sie
darf keine Zivilbevölkerung angreifen
und damit auch keine zivilen Objekte
also keine Wohnhäuser keine
Krankenhäuser keine Schulen im
Einzelfall ist im Krieg die amkretzung
aber gar nicht so schwer zum Teil wird
das auch natürlich missbraucht also wenn
z.B in einem Krankenhaus auch ein
Waffenlager ähm liegt oder wenn aus
einem Wohnhaus Raketen abgeschossen
werden dann wird plötzlich
völkerrechtlich aus einem zivilen
Gebäude ein militärisches Gebäude und
dann dürfte man das Angreifen natürlich
muss das verhältnismäßig sein und dazu
dafür damit das verhältnismäßig ist
könnte es helfen die Bevölkerung vorher
zu warnen aufzufordern ein Gebäude zu
verlassen oder auch eine Region zu
verlassen so wiee Israel das heute getan
hat ähm aber das Völkerrecht nimmt im
Endeffekt am Ende auch zivile Opfer in
Kauf als sogenannter lateralschaden
das muss man so sehen was schwierig ist
was problematisch ist denke ich ist z.B
die Abriegelung des gasastreifens wenn
da gar kein Strom kein Wasser kein
Benzin keine Lebensmittel mehr
reinkommen weil das natürlich vor allem
die Zivilbevölkerung betrifft das dürfte
auf längere Dauer sicherlich
völkerrechtlich problematisch sein auch
für die Hammers dürfte nach der
herrschenden Meinung dass humanitäre
Völkerrecht Anwendung finden so hat man
es z.B auch beim islamischen Staat
gesehen und man muss ganz klar sagen die
Taten die Angriffe die Verschleppung die
die Hammers da durchgeführt hat die
verstoßen natürlich ganz ganz klar gegen
das humanitäre Völkerrecht und sie
stellen nach allem was wir heute wissen
auch ganz klar Kriegsverbrechen da das
heißt man könnte die einzelnen Täter z.B
auch vor den Internationalen
Strafgerichtshof stellen aber dafür ist
natürlich Voraussetzung dass man sie
erstmal ermittelt ich weiß wei nicht ob
das über Videos und so weiter gelingt
und dass man sie dann irgendwann auch
bekommt das ist jetzt natürlich noch
sehr sehr weit entfernt da kommen also
im Verlauf dieses Krieges noch
verschiedene und Verlauf dieser
Auseinandersetzung verschiedene
Fragestellungen auf dem Tisch z.B die
Verletzung also des Völkerrechtes und
wir hatten hier Einschätzungen von Kolja
schwarz wir gehen zurück nach Israel
nach Tel Aviv wo sich Benjamin netanah
der nicht unumstrittene
Ministerpräsident der tatsächlich auch
einiges Aufarbeitung mit seinem Militär
haben wird im Nachgang der
Auseinandersetzungen der hat sich quasi
im Tagesrhythmus an seine Bevölkerung
bewandt auch gestern wieder da geht es
darum allen noch einmal Mut zu machen
die jetzt auch in sehr sehr großer Sorge
sind und bereits auch ihre Wohnorte
verlassen haben Benjamin netanaho Auszug
aus seiner Ansprache an die
Nation Bürger
israelabatalom für euch alle Schabbat
schalom für unsere
Streitkräfte unsere Streitkräfte die im
Lande sind überall und sie habenen
Sabbat weit weg von zu Hause
gefeiert heute heute verstehen wir alle
das es geht um das Haus wir kämpfen um
das Haus das Haus von uns allen wir
kämpfen wie
Löwen die Soldatinnen und Soldaten die
Polizistin und Polizisten die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger die
Streitkräfte und die Rettungskräfte und
ihr die Bürger
Israels mit diesem freiwilligen
Engagement wir sind alle rekrutiert wir
sind alle
vereint noch viel wird erzählt über
unsere Heldentaten in diesen Tagen in
diesen dunkelen Tagen wo wir Schmerz
haben von diesem schlechten bösen
Schabbat und das wird in die
Geschichte
des jüdischen Volkes geschrieben wir
werden nie vergessen über diese grultate
was uns gemacht ich habe mit einige
familieangehören
gesprochen ihre Welt ist
zerstört ich
weiß wir werden nie vergessen die
grultaten unsere Feinde und wir werden
nie verzeihen und wir werden der Welt
auch nicht zulassen oder
jemanden
dieseueltaten in Vergessenheit zu
bringen sowas ist noch nie passiert in
letzten 10 Jahren wir kämpfen und wir
schlagen unsere Feinde beispielslos ich
betone das ist nur der
Anfang unsere Feinde habe erst begonnen
nur den die Zeche zu bezahlen und ich
werde überhaupt nicht Detail gehen was
auf uns zukommt aber ich kann Ihnen
sagen dass ist nur der
Anfang bei meinen Gespräche mit
Präsidenten beiden und mit anderen
Führer in der Welt und mit großen Mühen
rekrutieren Israel ein internationale
Unterstützung für unsere Akten ich habe
heute den amerikanischen Außenminister
getroffen und die forung des Krieges wir
dadurch gesichert wir kriegen weitere
Munition und wir werden die Hamas
vernichten wir werden siegen es wird
noch dauern aber wir werden diesen Krieg
beendenärke als je
zuvor gott wird uns helfen gegen unsere
Feinde und sie werden
verabatalom Benjamin netanahu war das am
Freitagabend in telaviv und in Freiburg
sind wir jetzt verbunden mit Josef
kreuteru er Historiker Autor Journalist
undexerte geboren in Haifa danke dass
Sie sich Zeit nehmen wenn wir gemeinsam
jetzt zum S auf diese Äußerungen von
Herr netanaho dem israelischen Premier
schauen es ist klar dass er Mutmachen
will und Stärke demonstrieren aber die
Frage ist wie sehr ist auch das
Vertrauen der Bevölkerung nach den
Vorgängen des letzten Wochenendes
erschüttert ja guten Tag erstmal ja also
das Vertrauen ist in Israel sehr
erschüttert aber das betrifft natürlich
eher die Gegner der Regierung die schon
seit Wochen und Monaten auf die Straße
gehen um die Regierung netanyaho zu
protestieren und ihre Pläne das ist ein
anderes Thema da müssen wir jetzt uns
damit nicht befassen
netanu weiß das und deshalb sie haben ja
den Aspekt angesprochen dass er den
Israelis Mut machen will gleichzeitig
aber hat Netanyahu hier natürlich an die
an Emotionen appelliert an die eigene
Opferrolle
äh der
Israelis auch in Bezug auf die längere
Geschichte also die das Leid der Juden
in ihrre Geschichte und daavon versteht
er viel das tut er bei vielen
Gelegenheiten
und das ist von ihm bekannt also er ist
ein begab
geschickter Redner und das hat er hier
wieder demonstriert deswegen hat er es
ja auch so viele Male in dieses Amt auch
des Premierministers geschafft in
unterschiedlichen Konstellationen und
mit unterschiedlicher parteipolitischer
Stärke
wenn wir auf das schauen was vor Israel
liegt dann
kommt mir auch noch ein Satz des
israelischen Verteidigungsministers
galant in den Sinn der auch noch mal
dieser Tage gesagt hat was wir vor uns
haben ist ein offenbar sehr langer Krieg
eine sehr lange Auseinandersetzung sind
die Israelis darauf
eingestellt die Israelis sind sicherlich
darf eingestellt äh äh aber es hängt
auch damit zusammen dass die politische
Führung das schon seit einigen Tagen
auch insinuiert also man bereitet schon
seit äh äh den letzten Tagen äh die
Israelis darauf dass es eine
Bodenoffensive geben wird und dass der
Krieg lange dauern wird es gibt auch
Formen der mutmachung in der man sagt
oder verspricht dass man die Hamas auch
vernichten wir das wollen sicherlich
viele Israelis hören aber ob das am Ende
auch durchgesetzt wird ist natürlich
eine große
Frage es ist ein M starker Gegner und
ein schwer berechenbarer Gegner die
Hamas lassen Sie uns und Sie haben sich
lange mit dieser Terrororganisation so
ist sie gelabelt hier in Europa aber
durchaus auch in den USA lassen Sie uns
über Hamas und seine Unterstützer
sprechen vielleicht erst einmal zur
Organisationsstruktur man hat ja
durchaus den Eindruck da gibt es eine
sehr starke Verwurzelung täuscht dieser
Eindruck oder was können sie sozusagen
berichten
die Hamas ist ja in Gazastreifen
entstanden
Ende 87 als politische Organisation als
politische Bewegung sie ist ja erwachsen
aus der Bewegung der
Muslimbrüder im
gazerastreifen die es schon Jahrzehnte
zuvor gab die muslimbudder unter
ahm Yassin war ein ein
Schullehrer hatte sich aber erst in den
70er
Jahren so richtig formiert und konnte
sich im Gazastreifen
verbreitern nicht zuletzt weil das auch
den Israelis den israelischen Besatzern
damals genehm war denn die
Israelis hatten gerne gesehen
dass innerhalb der Bevölkerung eine
Opposition eine Gegnerschaft und
Rivalität wächst zu der sekularen
veratach Bewegung und die sekulare
vertachbewegung war damals der große
Gegner der israelischen
Besatzer die Hamas Bewegung entstand
eben als als politische Bewegung
Ende der 80er
Jahre es hat aber einige Zeit gedauert
bis sie dann auch militärische
Strukturen aufgebaut hatte das ist dann
der Pol der bewaffnete Arm der Hamas der
nenn sich alkassab Brigaden und dann
muss man auch bedenken dass die Hamas
auch soziale Strukturen hat das heißt
von Anfang an und das geht zurück auf
eben die soziale Arbeit der Muslim
Bruder im Gazastreifen sie hatten äh es
verstanden die Bevölkerung durch soziale
Projekte durch äh Arbeit
ähm auch medizinische Art medizinische
Leistungen in Moscheen und rund um
Moscheen für sich zu gewinnen und
deshalb ist die Hamas schon länger
gerade auch im Gazastreifen sehr stark
verwurzeltteru wir haben gleich
Gelegenheit weiterzus sprechen ich
bedanke mich für diese erste Runde z.B
auch über das Binnenverhältnis zwischen
fatach und Hamas und das
Kräfteverhältnis das nehmen wir gleich
wieder auf zuvor schauen wir meine Damen
und Herren noch einmal in die Region wir
haben schon festgestellt im Laufe der
Sendung dass es einen regen
reisetourismus gibt einen politischen
reisetourismus in erster Linie äh wo
verschiedene Spitzenpolitiker aus aller
Welt europäische aber vor allen Dingen
amerikanische unterwegs sind seit Tagen
um die gesprächsfäden und Kanäle offen
zualten einer der fleißigsten auf diesem
Gebiet ist Anthony Blinken der
amerikanische Außenminister der zunächst
in Israel gewesen ist dann in Jordanien
dann in Qatar und heute in Saudi-Arabien
ist dort seinen saudischen
abendskollegen fesal getroffen hat und
wir wollen jetzt hören was die beiden
vor ihrem Gespräch zu sagen
hatten es ist gut dass wir hier
Gelegenheit haben miteinander zu reden
das Königreich und die USA haben immer
sehr gut zusammengearbeitet auch im
Interesse der Regalen Sicherheit wir
leben ja in einer schwierigen Zeit in
der Region und insofern ist es eine
wichtige Gelegenheit für Sie und auch
für mich unsere Zusammenarbeit auch für
die regionale Sicherheit fortzusetzen
wir haben es mit einer sehr schwierigen
beunruhigenden Situation zu tun und vor
allen Dingen leidet die
Zivilbevölkerung auf beiden Seiten unter
dieser Situation und ich denke es ist
wichtig dass wir alle verurteilen dass
Zivilisten zum Ziel genommen werden in
welcher Form zu welcher Zeit von wem
auch immer ich denke es ist sehr klar
auch die Arabische Liga hat sich
entsprechend geäußert aber jetzt geht es
darum weiteres ziviles Leid zu vermeiden
wir müssen die Lage schnell
deeskalieren und wieder Frieden stiften
oder zumindestens dafür sorgen dass die
Waffen schweigen dann geht es auch darum
die
humanitäre Lage anzugehen die humanitäre
Lage in Gaza ist wirklich sehr schwierig
und wir müssen sicherstellen dass der
Zugang auch für humanitäre Hilfe möglich
ist das ist von entscheidender Bedeutung
und wir müssen
zusammenarbeiten um Wege zu finden wie
wir aus diesem Zyklus der Gewalt
herauskommen darauf müssen wir uns
konzentrieren ohne gemeinsame
Anstrengungen diesen ständigen Rückgriff
auf Gewalt zu beenden werden Zivilisten
immer leiden und Zivilisten auf beiden
Seiten werden immer den Preis zahlen und
ich hoffe wir finden Mittel und Wege um
die jetzige Situation zu deeskalieren
und dann zu einer Lösung
beizu
tragen ja es ist gut sie zu treffen ich
würde mir wünschen dass die Umstände
andere wären aber sie haben unter
Strichen dass wir eng zusammenarbeiten
und wir wissen diese Zusammenarbeit auch
sehr zu schätzen zunächst einmal möchte
ich sagen kein Land kann und sollte das
tolerieren was Israel erlitten hat ein
Angriff
der sich kaum mit Worten beschreiben
lässt indem mehr als
1300 Menschen abgeschlachtet wurden auch
staatsangehörige anderer Länder durch
die Hamas Hamas vertritt nicht das
palästinensische Volk und seine
legitimen bestremung für die Zukunft
Hamas will den Staat Israel zerstören
und Juden ermorden und es ist wichtig
dass die ganze Welt das so sieht und ich
denke jetzt ist der Zeit bekommen auch
mehr Klarheit zu schaffen was die Hamas
anbelangt während Israel sein
legitimeses Recht auf Verteidigung
seiner Bevölkerung verfolgte und
versucht sicherstellen dass so etwas nie
wieder passiert muss man natürlich auch
sagen dass es wichtig ist um die
Zivilisten zu kümmern es geht darum
sichere Gebiete in Gaza auszuweisen und
auch Korridore für humanitäre Hilfe zu
errichten niemand von wir sehen dass
Zivilisten leiden weder in Israel noch
in Gaza noch anderen Orts und es ist
wichtig dass wir zusammenarbeiten um
sicherzustellen dass es dazu kommt
außerdem müssen wir auch
zusammenarbeiten um sicherzustellen dass
dieser Konflikt sich nicht ausweitet ich
freue mich also auf unsere Gespräche die
USA und Saudiarabien arbeiten ja auch
sehr eng in anderen Bereichen und
Gebieten eng zusammen wo auch Frieden
und Sicherheit wichtig sind dazu gehören
Jemen und der Sudan und vielen Dank für
den Empfang und auch für die
bevorstehenden
Gespräche das ist ein klein wenig wie
auf Splittern zu tanzen für Anthony
blinken und für seinen amendskollegen
facal bin fallah den saudischen
Außenminister
fahren wir waren stehenblieben her
kuteru bei der Frage
wie man innerhalb der Palästinenser das
Kräfteverhältnis bewerten muss die Hamas
davon ist jetzt auch gerade auch in
diesem Statement die Rede gewesen die
den Terrorangriff auf Israel verübt hat
aber eben auch die fatach Herr Abbas ist
ruhig geblieben er hat diese
Terrorangriffe nicht verurteilt wie
stark ist er noch wie muss man sich das
vorstellen das
binenverhältnis nein nein mahm ab hat
diese dies Angriff doch verurteilt ein
bisschen kritisiert aber verurteilt
würde ich so nicht sagen also so ist das
nicht angekommen hier in Deutschland D
ja gut ist eine Frage der Interpretation
natürlich ja also die palästinensische
politische Landschaft ist schon länger
geteilt es ist eigentlich so auch
schon seit dieser Zeit die ich schon
genannt habe seit der Entstehung der
hamasbewegung die die eigentlich
angeschlossen also innerhalb der PLO
hatte ja irgendwann
ihren bewaffneten Kampf gegen Israel
aufgegeben und mit Israel dann ein
Friedensabkommen abgeschlossen
die Hamas hatte von Anfang an all diese
Annährungsversuche an Israel zu
torpedieren versucht
in den 90er Jahren mit der schrecklichen
Waffe der
Selbstmordattentate was sie dann auch
Anfang der 2000 Jahre gemacht hatte und
letztendlich kam es zu einem absoluten
Showdown 2007 im Gasastreifen wo sie
dann die fatach vertrieben hatte und die
Macht übernommen hatte mit Gewalt und
seitdem herrscht sie im Gazastreifen und
hat eigentlich einen eigenen semistaat
aufgebaut hat aber gleichzeitig den SPR
auf die Führung des palästinensischen
Volkes also was wir schon seit Jahren
haben sind im Grunde zwei semis Staaten
die Palästinensische
Autonomiebehörde in der Westbank und
dieser Staats pseudostaatswesen der
Hamas das muss man sich einfach
vorstellen da gibt es parallel einfach
Ministerien Regierungsbehörden es ist da
eine Verdoppelung entstanden und
ähm die Autonomiebehörde in der Westbank
kooperiert ja auch gerade im
sicherheitsbereit Bereich mit den
Israelis das ist eine vollkommen andere
Situation als bei der Hamas die ja zwar
Israel immer noch nicht anerkennen will
aber momentan wird wie ich finde
komplett vergessen dass die Hamas 2017
ihr politisches Programm neu formuliert
hatte und sich dabei eher also deutlich
gemäsigter
zeigte wir haben gerade einen Stop
gemacht gemeinsam mit Anthony blinken in
Saudi-Arabien das bringt uns noch einmal
zu einer Entwicklung die im Grunde
genommen im Vorfeld dieser dieses
terrorangriffs vom letzten Wochenende
stand nämlich die Annäherung Israels an
die arabische Welt und der Gedanke auch
eines möglichen Frieden Schlusses mit
Saudi-Arabien eines formellen Abkommens
dieses ist ja nun mehr oder weniger vom
Tisch gefegt wie schätzen Sie das ein
ist da noch einmal ein wieder aufleben
denkbar wie schätzen sie sozusagen da
die Gemengelage
ein Nein ich danke ich ich glaube das
ist jetzt gerade machbar also was wir
jetzt gesehen haben dieses Treffen der
beiden Außenminister ist ja im Grunde
präzedenzlos den
blinken verurteilt in Anwesenheit des
saudischen Außenministers den
Terrorangriff auf Israel und
der saudische Kollege widerspricht ih
nicht also wir haben h eine wirklich
ganz neue Situation dass Saudi-Arabien
das ja auch den terorangriff selbst
schon verurteilt hat
sich den also den USA so nah steht dass
es eigentlich auch schon
in Verhandlungen mit Israel treten
könnte und die Hamas gehört ja ein Achse
darunter ist Iran darunter ist der
Satellit des Iran die hisbullah im
Libanon äh auch Syrien das ist eine
Achse die äh feindlich gegenüber steht
einer anderen Konstellation von Staaten
in der Region zu denen gehören auch eben
diese Golfstaaten die mit Israel schon
ein Friedensabkommen abgeschlossen haben
also es könnte sein dass wenn man
diesmal militärisch die Hamas sehr stark
dezimiert
das könnte ja neue Chancen eröffnen wenn
auch noch
Saudi-Arabien sozusagen Teil dieser
neuen Koalition sein wird
und dann ist dann wirklich noch alles
offen in den saudischen israelischen
Beziehungen das bringt uns zu den
geopolitischen Aussichten die wir gleich
in unserem gesitten Gesprächsteil
miteinander aufnehmen können vielen Dank
für diese zweite Runde Josef kuteru
Historiker na aostexperte Autor danke
erstmal nach Freiburg meine Damen und
Herren und wir gehen einen Schritt
weiter vom Libanon ist schon die Rede
gewesen und vom Iran auch und das ist
eine komplizierte Gemengelage gest dann
war der iranische
Außenminister
abdullan in
Beirut danach gab es diese Äußerungen
von ihm die wir gleich noch mal etwas
näher analysieren
können die amerikanische Seite schickt
verschiedene Botschaften an
verschiedenen
Parteien die USA fordern alle Parteien
zur Zurückhaltung auf und zeigen sich
sehr besorgt über die Ausweitung des
Krieges
محدار
dassen
Einung dass die verbrech in dem fschen
gebde und Frauen Kinder und
inمر staten können nicht einerseits alle
Parteien zu Zurückhaltung auffordern
während sie andererseits Waffen und
Bomben schicken um Frauen Kinder und
Zivilisten in Gaza zu töten wenn diese
Verbrechen Kriegsverbrechen die vom
fschen zionistischen Gebilde begangen
werden nicht sofort aufhören dann ist
jede Möglichkeit
denkbar das war die Äußerung gestern in
Beirut und wir wollen uns noch eine
weitere Äußerungen
hineinholen wir haben schon über die
vertachtbewegung gesprochen auch über
diese schwierige Stellung innerhalb des
palästinensischen Gefüges gegenüber
Hamas und wollen das noch einmal neu mit
einem kleinen oton würzen den wir
eingefangen haben gestern in ramala
durch den dortigen premier also nicht
den Präsidenten ab abas sondern durch
den Premier und wenn wir das gesprochen
haben wenn wir das gezeigt haben dann
noch mal das Gespräch mit Herrn
kutero der palästin das palästinensische
Volk erlebt
Massaker in
Gaza und durch tägliche
Angriffe der Siedler auf unsere Menschen
im Westjordanland mehr als 44 Menschen
wurden umgebracht von der Armee und von
den Siedlern was in Gaza passiert ist
ist ein echtes
Massaker eine völlige Unterbrechung der
Wasserversorgung und der
verersorgung völlige Zerstörung von
privaten Gebäuden öffentlichen Gebäuden
und der
Infrastruktur und wir sehen dass diese
internationale Unterstützung für Israel
nichts meh ist als eine Ermutigung für
Israel noch mehr Verbrechen gegen unser
Volk zu verüben unser Präsident hat mit
internationalen Staats und
Regierungschefs gesprochen heute
Vormittag hat er sich mit Außenminister
blinken getroffen und wir fordern die
sofortige Einstellung der Angriffe auf
unsere Leute in Gaza sicheres Geleit
damit notwendige medizinische Güter und
Lebensmittel möglich sind und unsere
verletzen behandelt werden können die
Krankenhäuser haben wahrscheinlich nur
noch für z bis D Tage Brennstoff und
wenn die Krankenhäuser keinen Strom und
kein Brennstoff mehr haben dann bedeutet
es dass alle krankenhäus in
Gaza
massenfriedhöfe für die Menschen die
jetzt schon fast tot sind und verletzt
sind werden diese Situation ist eine
Katastrophe ist eine ethnische Säuberung
und wenn die israelische Armee jetzt
befieht bzweise fordert dass unsere
Menschen vertrieben werden vom Norden
hin zum Süden des Gazastreifens wenn
gleichzeitig der Süden von Gaza
bombardiert
wird dann weisen wir das zurück diese
Art der Umsiedlung von Palästinensern
gibt es ja seit 1950
wir lehnen diesen Plan von Israel und
seinen Unterstützern vollig ab die
Palästinenser haben elende Tage erlebt
wir werden aber unsere Heimat nicht
verlassen Gaza zu verlassen ist nicht
möglich wir stehen ein für unser Land
für unsere Heimat und jede Vertreibung
bedeutet dass es keine Rückkehr mehr
geben wird dass es unumkehrbar wurde und
das wird nicht passieren wir leisten
Widerstand dagegen unsere Menschen haben
das Recht ein menschenwürdiges Leben zu
führen in einem freien Palästina in
einem befreiten Palästina in einem
unabhängigen souveränen Staat mit
Jerusalem als Hauptstadt mit dem
Westjordanland und gasan diese Situation
darf nicht anhalten Präsident abas hat
es auch in seiner Rede vor den
verereinten Nation klar gemachte dass
die Fortführung dieser Maßnahme gegen
unser Volk zu einer sehr aufgeheizten
Situation führen wird das haben wir
erlebt und alles was wir wollen ist dass
dieses Massaker jetzt aufhört und nicht
erst
morgen das also noch die Äußerung aus
ramala und das bringt uns zurück nach
Freiburg zu Josef kuteru Historiker
autorner ostexpert her
grteru lassen Sie uns bei einer dieser
Aussagen beginnen
wir verlassen Gaza nicht wir bleiben
hier angesichts dieses
evakuierungsaufrufes ne und wir sind ja
sozusagen in der Aktualität und nicht in
der
Zukunft was heißt das heißt das ich
warte ab bis die Panzer kommen das kann
nicht der ernst sein von der
Autonomiebehörde ja gut die
Autonomiebehörde in der Westbank hat
überhaupt keine Kontrolle über das
Geschehen im gaserstreifen nicht al das
haben wir doch gerade erläutert
so dass auch diese Rede im Rahmen des
symbolischen verhart
und man muss aber auch gleichzeitig wenn
man sie genauer studiert bedenken dass
der palästinensische Ministerpräsident
kein einziges Wort über die Hamas
verloren hat hat sie nicht erwähnt hat
auch gesagt dass unsere Leute
Widerstand
leisteten welche Leute das sind bleibt
eben offen also äh die
äh Palästinensische Autonomiebehörde in
der Westbank hat natürlich als legitime
Vertreterin des palästinensischen Volkes
in dieser Zeit die Aufgabe in Namen der
palästinensischen Bevölkerung egal wo
sie jetzt ist ob im gazerastreifen oder
in der Westbank zu sprechen und Ihre
Belange in die Weltöffentlichkeit zu
tragen das hat jetzt äh der
Ministerpräsident getan
ähm lassen Sie uns noch einmal schauen
auf das was wir vorher gehört haben
ähm und zwar die Äußerungen des
iranischen Außenministers getätigt in
Beirut m wo steuert das hin Iran ist ein
ganz großer Player in der Region und ein
Unterstützer ja also der bei der der
Betonung der der Opferrolle der der
Palästinenser haben sich natürlich beide
reden überschnitten aber nicht weil Iran
sich so sehr um die
Palästinenser ja Sorgen macht sondern
weil Iran schon seit vielen Jahren die
palästinensische Lage für seine
expansionistische Politik in der Region
instrumentalisiert Iran ist eine der
UnterstützerInnen der hamasbewegung aber
auch nicht die einzige und Iran droht ja
schon seit vielen Jahren Israel in allen
möglichen Gelegenheiten es gibt auch den
alten Spruch von chumeni der ständig auf
wieder aufgewärmt wird von der
Vernichtung Israels
ähm ich könnte mir also nicht vorstellen
dass ein iranischer Vertreter äh eine
andere Rede in dieser Situation gehalten
hätte es sind auch es ist es ist
Symbolpolitik der
betreibt gibt es denn aus ihrer Sicht
mit den Erkenntnissen die sie haben
Belege dafür für die Unterstützung des
Irans für diese ja
Kommandoaktion von Hamas von der es ja
heißt dass sie bis zu zwei Jahre lang
vorbereitet
wurde es es kursieren inzwischen
verschiedene Versionen aber die dieser
Großangriff war sagen wir mal in
militärischer Hinsicht einfach eine
gründlich geplante und organisierte
Aktion
ähm es wurden so wie ich dass sehe
einfach eine Reihe von kleinen Gruppen
von Kämpfern ausgebildet und genau
unterrichtet über ihre einzelne Mission
keine von denen wusste was genau dann
letztendlich damit geschieht sicherlich
gab es auch keine Kommunikation
dazwischen bis zur letzten Minute wusste
außer einem ganz engen Kreis von
Eingeweihten offensichtlich nichts von
dieser Aktion
also wichtig war einfach die
Informationsbeschaffung die Aufklärung
die auf Seite der Hamas betrieben wurde
offensichtlich mit Hilfe von Dr sie hat
die israelischen Militärbasen über
längere Zeit gut beobachtet und gewusst
haben wie es sich dort verhält auch mit
der mit den vorhandenen
Mannschaften so dass ich hier nicht
unbedingt die
inzwischen
beschworene große Hilfe des
Iran als unbedingt notwendige se das
hätte ja auch ohne weiteres gehen ja und
die israelische Militärführung hat ja
mittlerweile auch eine gewisse
Blauäugigkeit offenbar in den letzten
Monaten eingestanden also dieses wird
noch einmal aufzuarbeiten sein wenn wir
gemeinsam noch zum Abschluss unseres
Gespräches ein bisschen in die Zukunft
schauen wir hatten die Geopolitik
angesprochen
man schaut dann ein bisschen
international und schaut gibt es
irgendwelche stabilen Vermittler auch
für die Formulierung eines ausweges die
ja irgendwann nach einer kriegerischen
Auseinandersetzung dann zu finden sein
wird gibt es eine stabile Partei
Position Figur die von beiden Seiten
Anerkennung finden könnte sehen sie da
jemanden oder eine
Nation also es kann nur eine eine eine
Gruppe sein von von Staaten und in
dieser Gruppe müssen eben
sowohl solche die der Hamas einigermaßen
nah stehen als auch solche die mit der
Hamas in Kontakt sind und sonst einfach
auch eine ja eine Großmacht äh und
ich glaube es zeichnet sich schon durch
ab durch eine ägyptische Initiative
Ägypten ist ja ein ganz wichtiger
Vermittler zwischen Israel und der Hamas
in den letzten Jahren gewesen
und
Ägypten hat angedeutet dass es eine
regionale Konferenz veranstalten wird
und darin werden auch Qatar sein also
Qatar unterstütztte Hamas vor allem fin
als auch eventuell
Saudi-Arabien und die USA
das ist durchaus
aussichtsvoll und könnte zumindest zu
einer
Befriedigung Befriedung der Lage führen
und vielleicht auch neue Chancen
eröffnen her noch ein letzter Punkt die
Europäer haben sie in ihrer Aufzählung
jetzt wohlweißlich denke ich nicht gen
genannt weil sie mittlerweile nicht mehr
den Status haben sozusagen des
Vermittlers der von allen Seiten
akzeptiert ist aber was interessant ist
wenn wir noch einmal am Eingang unseres
Gespräches hatten wir Herr netanaho der
gesagt hat ich vernichte die Hamas das
ist unser gemeinsames Ziel wenn sie
sagen dass in einer Vermittlung dann der
herramas noch mit am Tisch ist dann
würden sie bezweifeln dass Israel dies
gelingt nämlich die Hamas zu vernichten
so wie es Herr netanaho formuliert hat
heißt das habe ich das richtig
verstanden nein also die äh die Hamas
ist nicht vorgesehen für diese Konferenz
nein es sind einfach nur
Staaten die äh in Kontakt mit der Hamas
sind aber die Hamas wird man nicht in
Gaza Streifen selbst wenn das äh mit
voller Wucht durchgezogen wird
vernichten können denn von Anfang an
hatte die Hamas darauf
geachtet ein Teil ihrer politischen
Führung später auch ein Teil ihrer
militärischen Führung im Ausland zu
behalten
das ist die Situation einer Organisation
die auch ständig ihre geheime also die
klandestine Struktur verteidigt und eben
sie deshalb auch ins Auslang immer
verlegt hat also die Hamas wird nicht
von der Landkarte verschwinden auf
keinen Fall das war ein großer Mehrwert
heute Mittag mit ihn war phix zu
sprechen Josef kuteru war das Historiker
ostexperte Autor ich danke Ihnen
herzlich für Ihre Zeit Größe nach
Freiburg danke schön ich danke Ihnen
auch alles Gute schalom meine Damen und
Herren das war M 60 Minuten das was wir
zur Stunde berichten können aus dem
Nahen Osten äh rund um die Vorgänge im
gaserstreifen und in Israel wir werden
weiter ein Auge darauf haben
gleichzeitig haben wir bei phöniix ein
Auge darauf was an diesem Wochenende das
ist für Europa auch eine sehr wichtige
Hausnummer in Polen passieren wird eine
Richtungsentscheidung bei den kommenden
Parlamentswahlen dazu werden wir morgen
Abend berichten und jetzt schon haben
wir das was Sie von uns kennen ein
phöniix Plus wir schauen etwas tieferhin
gute Information bei phöniix
danke